should I just did a cheek swab? A chiropractor also muscle tests the
for supplements and he wants me to take nine rolamine iodine. That's a product of standard
process. My latest muscle test with you said no. That supplement I'm confused now. There are many
sources say iodine is good for healing breast cancer please explain. Yeah well you can have
differences in testing so you're just going to have to make a decision on your own when you have
a difference of opinion from two different practitioners. It didn't test well with you this time
so that's why I put dough. I don't give something just because you know there's there's several books
written on iodine and breast cancer. Well you know you have to be careful with everything right
but you have to be careful with iodine because iodine any long term use of iodine is you have a
much higher chance of developing Hashimoto's when you have an auto new disease that's cool morbidity
cancer it makes treating the cancer even more difficult so you know even if it muscle even if iodine
muscle tested well I would still personally recommend doing a complete thyroid panel now you could
do a complete thyroid panel within our complete wellness panel because it's in that but a complete
thyroid panel remember it contains T3, T4, Reverse T3, TSH, TPO antibodies, ethyroglabin and antibodies
at the very least. So getting that done would be wise if those were all normal your thyroid was all
normal then you could pursue it's perceived with caution but if you have any type of primary
hypothyroidism there's been studies down that if you have primary hyperhypathyroidism and you take iodine
it's almost a hundred percent guarantee we literally in this one study in Japan
354 women with primary hypothyroidism put them on iodine within three to six months every single
patient and Hashimoto's so every single patient let me primary hypothyroidism is diagnosed as
someone with low thyroid but does not have any autoimmune they don't have any
elevation of TPO antibodies of thyroid probably antibodies for every single person because thyroid is so
specific or because iodine is so specific to the thyroid it can stimulate an immune response
to the thyroid especially if you're taking a bunch of immune stimulators for cancer you're using
immune stimulators to try to kill your cancer and then you take iodine it can stimulate an immune
response to the thyroid that's how it ends up working that you adapt to developing antibodies to the
thyroid so I would just be cautious in that you can do what you want you know and everything you're
going to have to pray about your decision but I don't think we'd have good practitioners if they didn't
have some disagreements for other some things